We all exaggerate and lie, but when we are alone online
Our Google search record quickly reveals the truth
Using more than 3 billion searches a day
We can discover a lot about human desires and our secret concerns
So how much does this data reflect you?
First, people suffer to have sex
Searches for "sexless" are 3.5 times more than "unhappy marriages"
And 8 times more common than "marriage without love"
Despite the prevailing assumption that women's sexual appetite is lower than that of men
The likelihood of women looking for the phrase "my friend does not want to have sex with me" is twice that of men
Who are looking for "my girlfriend do not want to have sex with me"
If you are worried that you do not have sex as much as others do
They know that they are exaggerating too
In view of gender (between man and woman), an expanded referendum found that
Women say they have sex 55 times a year, using a condom 16% of the time
Which means 1.1 billion condoms a year
Similarly, men claim to use 1.6 billion condoms
While in America, only 600 million condoms are sold per year.
The lack of sex may be rooted in the lack of self-confidence in the body
Not surprisingly, men search Google for their bars
More than any other member,
In fact, even more than their total search for lung, liver, foot, ear, nose, throat and brain are combined.
In return for every search conducted by a woman about her partner's penis
There are 170 searches by the man about his penis.
But, men, do not worry too much about the issue of size
40% of women complain that the penis is too large to be painful.
When a woman conducts a research related to her disability
By 30%, the questions relate to the opinion of others, especially the smell
Also, women are looking for how to make a better lymphoma, twice more than men.
When a man is looking for oral sex tips
They are looking for how to perform for the partner
Just as much as they are looking for how they perform for themselves.
Speaking of pornography, it is among the top 100 searches on Bourne
There are 16 searches for men incest, and 9 for women
Such as "brother and sister", "father's wife", "father and daughter", "real brother and sister"
Pornographic searches can also answer important questions about sexuality in humans.
In America, a 5% share of research among men relates to male relativity
But survey data and Facebook reports show that only 2 to 3 percent of men know themselves as gay
Number of men who identify themselves as gay in public
Doubles in Rhode Island, the most supportive state for gay marriage
Compared to Mississippi, a less supportive state.
One explanation may be that those living in less forgiving states move to more tolerant states
But statistics show that this interpretation only applies to half of this difference
Unfortunately, millions of Americans are hiding their truth.
Combine this with Google's autocomplete data, which is calibrated based on the most popular research
You'll find that once you start typing "Do my husband"
Will be added to "gay"
Women write this with a probability of 10% greater than they say "Does my husband betray me"
It is the second most common choice.
In 21 states out of 25, where the phrase "Is my husband gay" more prevalent.
Support for gay marriage was below the national average.
This also applies to transgender meetings on Krajigslist
Where ads from men are looking for more men in less forgiving states
Up to the maximum in Kentucky, Louisiana and Alabama
Google AutoComplete will not suggest some words, which it thinks are inappropriate
Such as "cock" or "porn", but if you say "Is it normal to want to .."
Google used to complete the word "kill"
Similarly, only a few want to acknowledge remorse for having children
But adults with children are 3.6 times more likely
In telling Google to regret having children of adults without children
Who regret not having children.
Google also tells us how racism is still alive and well
The prefix with the letter "N" appears in searches with the same proportion as the "Lakers"
And "hemorrhagic", of which 20% includes the words "jokes"
On the first night of Obama's election in 2008, most analyzes were focused on
Praise for this historic night
One out of every 100 searches for Obama's word
The term KKK, or the word N, is included
Typically, many assume that most racism exists in the southern states
But the highest results of racial research were in northern New York, western Pennsylvania and eastern Ohio.
Statistics scientist Net Silver found the highest statistical correlation to predict Trump's basic support
It was not unemployment, arms, religion, or immigration
But he was searching Google for the word N
Facebook data scientists used personal status publications to measure total happiness for a day
Christmas seems to be the happiest day of the year
This appears in Gallup surveys and Google searches as well
But it is also necessary to be skeptical of what people see on social media
The respected Atlantic magazine has 1.5 million followers on Twitter
While there are only 18,000 followers of the National Enquirer, the magazine Nimeema
But both have the same proportion of paper and virtual distribution.
Or imagine the difference between a woman and her husband on Facebook and what he describes on Google
On Facebook, the most commonly used phrases to describe a pair are
Best, favorite friend, wonderful, great, very tender
While the top searches on Google related to the pair will be
Gay, idiot, gorgeous, annoying, lame
We decided to take a look at the history record of each of us
We discovered very interesting things about each other
You can watch the video by clicking here
Research in this episode relied on the wonderful book "All People Lied"
By Seth Stevens-Davids
Highly recommend it. Subscribe to receive more weekly science videos every Thursday.
Translation: team translate